[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Subscribe to stay in the know.
The Android N APIs are final.
It's time to get
your apps ready.
So if you haven't already,
download the final SDK
for Android N through the SDK
Manager in Android Studio.
Also, you can now
publish updates
compiling with and
optionally targeting API 24
to Google Play, which
means you can start testing
your app on the
alpha/beta, or even
production, channels with the
Google Play Developer console.
Hit up the post
for all the links.
One year ago, we added
Android Security Rewards
to the longstanding Google
Vulnerability Rewards Program.
Since then, we've paid
over half a million dollars
to 82 researchers.
And you know what?
For reports filed after June
1, we're starting to pay more.
The post has all the details.
Have you ever wanted your own
scalable location analysis
platform?
Well, check out the post for a
full tutorial and docker images
for one built with the Google
Cloud Platform and Google Maps
APIs.
The GCloud tool is your
gateway to manage and interact
with the Google Cloud Platform
from the command line.
Check out the post
for some details,
including a demonstration
of filters, formatting,
and projections.
At Google I/O 2016, we launched
a new Google Sheets API.
The update includes
new features,
including access
to functionality
found in the Sheets desktop,
and mobile user interfaces.
Follow the link below for an
introduction and some code.
Within one month of implementing
AdMob native ads, [INAUDIBLE]
saw its total revenue
increase by 10%.
From just one native ad
slot, they earned over $4,000
in a single day.
To learn more, read the full
case study linked below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]